hey everybody it's Mike Freer here with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control
ca.l2-3.12.1 periodically it's just the
security controls and organizational
systems to determine if the controls are
effective in their application
[Music]
so hey if you're a contractor who's
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone try
to understand all this cmmc dfars and
nist SP 800 171 compliance stuff on top
of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it so in
ca.l2-3.12.1 periodically assess the
security controls and organizational
systems to determine if the controls are
effective in their application this is
one of those controls that will get the
it guys head scratching and for good
reason this isn't really an I.T issue
for the most part okay so again remember
dfar's nist compliance is a company-wide
issue and not everything is all on the
it guy's head so this is a risk
management control okay not an I.T
control and as we are beginning to learn
dfar's nist cmmc they're all far more
about risk management than directly
about cyber security so here the
assessors are going to want to
understand hey what is your risk
management program look like how often
are you actually looking at risk and the
way you are managing it and let me tell
you it better be documented in a policy
somewhere and you better be able to
prove you're actually getting getting
into it and acting on it not just some
Word document from 1997 that hasn't been
opened in a million years okay because
again these assessors are sharp they're
going to be able to sit there and look
at date and time stamps on files with
you they're going to kind of see through
the letters they're going to want to see
hey show me some calendar entry where
you had an actual meeting about risk
management as a sidebar this control is
one that is solved with our virtual
compliance officer services so again if
you're a small to mid-sized company or
even a large company and you're like man
I don't know how to do this I don't you
know we don't have risk management
practices in our business and you know
you're just kind of like shaking your
head thinking yourself what on Earth am
I going to do here we literally handle
this for our clients right now let's
dive into what the assessors are looking
for so you can learn at least how to
solve for it
so in this control we're looking for two
different things number one uh determine
if the frequency of security control
assessments is defined in other words is
there somewhere in writing where you're
stating how often security assessments
uh of you know are happening and and how
often those controls are actually
assessed to see if they're working so in
our case if we were to sort of be
managing this for a client we would say
Hey look it's implemented via the risk
management standard operating procedure
again one of the things we deliver for
our clients is we deliver a complete set
of standard operating procedures which
includes a risk management policy a risk
management framework and everything that
goes along with managing risk the second
thing they'd be looking for is
determining if security controls are
assessed with the defined frequency to
determine if the controls are effective
in their application if that sounded a
whole lot like the first thing they're
looking for let's hit the rewind button
and let's try it again so again the
first thing they're looking for is the
frequency of security control assessment
the second thing they're looking for is
determine if security controls are
assessed with the defined frequencies so
again they're just really kind of diving
in to prove the point that they're going
to have to have some evidence that
you're actually participating in these
risk management activities and that
you're actually assessing whether or not
the security controls are really there
are really working are really effective
in their utilization and whether or not
you're assessing if they actually are
you know bad or good again how do we
answer that second that second piece of
assessment we would say hey it's
implemented via the risk management sop
in addition you can also see the
Baseline configuration the network
inventory and the poem because again
these are going to be things that change
as new risks are realized and come onto
the scene they'll be discussing your
risk management program and then again
you would see those changes throughout
changes in additions to your plan of
actual Milestones system security plans
and things like that so if your head is
spinning like mine is sometimes when I
talk about risk management the good news
is here at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who've had
this dfars nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped into their laps like a
seal on a sunny day we teach you how to
level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
information on getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmccompliance secrets.com
or check out the Bible below for links
to get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance stores roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you